des paquets de cigarettes sans logo à ni
couleur et peut-être supprimer des
linéaires c'est ce que prévoit le projet
de Bruxelles dans le cadre de la lutte
contre le tabagisme de quoi provoquer la
colère des buralistes jeudi dernier et
il manifestait un peu partout en France
ils ont placé des draps blancs devant
leur rayon bonsoir Jean-François
Vigouroux vous êtes le président dans
les Yvelines de la chambre syndicaliste
des buralistes vous avez participé à
cette opération jeudi dernier quelques
jours après maintenant que les choses se
sont un petit peu tassées quel bilan
vous en faites ça a servi à quelque
chose
on s'est fait entendre et je pense que
c'est un ballon d'essai et on a été reçu
comme il se devait et donc il y a des
choses qui sont sorties des réunions
justement le syndicat a pu non non
l'augmentation du tabac nous allons la
voir
d'ici 1er octobre par contre ce qu'on
veut c'est des augmentations
tempérées c'est 40 centimes c'est énorme
et on parlait une augmentation à la 30 à
40 centimes par paquet avant ou plutôt
le 1er octobre vous demandez quoi comme
augmentation faut que ce soit
significatif aussi parce que oui mais 40
centimes c'est la plus grosse
augmentation depuis 2003 l'année où il y
a eu cette si grosse augmentation et qui
nous a fait perdre du volume et des
buralistes donc une augmentation oui
mais calculer tempéré dans le temps
parce que c'est pas avec des
augmentations comme ça qu'on arrivera à
stopper définitivement de toute façon le
tabac le sentiment que ça peut te donner
aussi au grand public c'est qu'il y a un
plan petit tabac qui peut se mettre en
place et que ce sont les buralistes qui
sont contre ce plan petit tabac est-ce
que c'est le cas vous êtes contre les
plans antitamment on est pour la santé
publique par contre on est où la nuance
pour la santé publique on n'est pas
contre la santé publique par contre mais
on veut protéger nos affaires quoi
aujourd'hui on est sous un organisme de
tutelle on nous demande des choses on le
on le fait par contre
si on augmente le paquet de tabac à la
vitesse où ils veulent le faire avec le
paquet générique qui va et
c'est la fin de du métier on peut
concilier le fait de mener une politique
anti-tabac et de réduire la consommation
en France et en même temps de garder
l'activité libéraliste
oui on peut le faire mais la première
chose à faire à mon avis c'est de lutter
contre la contrebande car aujourd'hui il
faut bien savoir que 21% du tabac
consommer en France et vendu par la
contrebande ce qui représente un paquet
sur cinq donc ils l'ont prouvé et par
contre aucune étude n'a été faite sur
l'utilité des photoshops sur les paquets
comme aucune étude n'a été faite sur le
paquet générique donc notre président
pendant sa campagne nous avait dit nous
attendrons de voir ce que les résultats
de l'Australie on s'aperçoit que c'est à
peine mis en place qu'on veut déjà le
faire en France donc pas confondre
vitesse et précipitations donc ça veut
dire que pour vous ou quoi à terme il
faudra toute façon à freiner cette
consommation du tabac mais mettons par
exemple vous parlez de lutter contre les
systèmes qui se mettent en place pour
approvisionner les consommateurs en
tabac par des filières parallèles
mettons que le gouvernement lutte
activement contre ces filières vous
accepteriez pour autant des
augmentations
de tabac on aurait même en baissant nos
volumes
ça irait le problème c'est que en
augmentant de 40 centimes comme il va y
avoir le mois prochain c'est encore plus
de marché parallèles parce que les gens
n'arrêtent pas de fumer les gens fument
différemment écoutez des politiques on
entend aussi souvent ça et pas seulement
des politiques il faut diversifier les
activités des buralistes c'est là la clé
pour l'avenir est-ce que c'est aussi
c'est ce qu'on a déjà fait c'est ce
qu'on vend des timbres fiscaux on est un
bois des matérialisés on essaye de faire
plein de choses mais remplacer le tabac
c'est pour vous faudra toujours garder
du tabac de toute façon le tabac
l'interdire je ne pense pas que il
faille interdire parce que ce qui est
interdit on aime les interdits par
contre faire de la prévention
de l'enseignement expliqué des causes
maintenant un fumeur s'il a envie de
fumer vous pouvez pas l'empêcher faut
arrêter vos activités je reviens sur ça
de diversifier les activités de la
profession c'est ce que vous avez mis en
place dans votre établissement vous êtes
buraliste sur la ville de Maurepas
on essaye de se développer à faire nous
nous sommes une brasserie bar bon on
fait les jeux on fait les Tim fiscaux
les thèmes postaux enfin tout ce que on
peut les piles enfin tout ce qu'on
pourrait essayer de trouver qu'on trouve
pas ailleurs maintenant remplacer le
tabac souvent les gens viennent acheter
du tabac et en profite pour acheter
autre chose à côté donc si les gens ne
viennent plus pour le tabac
malheureusement je ne sais pas si on
arrivera
liste que vous diffusez quoi ce soir
c'est quoi c'est le tabac tout de même
c'est pas bon le tabac n'est pas bon
mais mais il faut qu'on vive parce que
tous les buralistes ont nous sommes 348
dans les Yvelines on a tous besoin de
vivre donc tout le monde a investi dans
son fonds de commerce donc aujourd'hui
si on nous dit votre bureau de tabac
vous avez plus le droit de vendre de ta
bac que devient-on faut-il un plan
anti-tabac en France c'est la question
que nous avons posée dans les rues de 50
ans en Yvelines pardon vos réponses
d'augmenter les prix des paquets vu que
ceux qui auront les moyens auront
toujours l'occasion d'acheter bon ce
qu'on fait les moyens après bon ce
serait notre histoire oui je pense que
ce serait bien tout simplement dans pour
la santé des gens non non parce que
toute façon un plan petit à bas ça
servir à rien ça n'empêche pas de fumer
il y a toujours la tentation et puis il
est fumeurs fumeront toujours quoi que
ce soit le prix ou qu'est-ce qui se
passe mis en place il y aura toujours
des fumeurs moi je dirais non parce que
façon même si ils augmentent les prix
les fumeurs ils vont toujours acheter
donc
moi je dirais plus que c'est pour les
caisses de l'État qu'ils augmentent les
prix voilà quoi simplement non non
pourquoi et ben parce que il y a toute
la contrebande qui arrive et ça c'est du
marché parallèle donc nous les fumeurs
on sait ce qu'on veut fumer exactement
donc restons en France
effectivement ça le témoignage rejoint
ce que vous nous disiez tout à l'heure
sur le plateau cette idée de développer
la contrebande c'est ce que le sentiment
de partager cette visiblement
consommatrice de tabac une dernière
question vous êtes immobilisé la semaine
dernière jeudi dernier avec cette
opération contre les plans anti-tabac
qui se prépare en Europe et en France la
suite de vos actions on attend de voir
avec la Confédération
comment ça va comment avoir avancer les
choses le ressenti sur le terrain c'est
que je pense que jamais les buralistes
n'ont été autant mobilisés et ils se
sont ils sont prêts à se mobiliser en
tout cas plus merci Jean-François Rigaud
d'être venu sur ce plateau je rappelle
que vous êtes président dans les
Yvelines de la Chambre Syndicale début
réaliste et que ce fameux plan
anti-tabac devrait être présenté d'ici
la fin du mois par le gouvernement merci
merci à vous voici à présent le rappel
des titres de ceux 11 septembre une
résidence eu universitaires sur quatre
étages construites en bois c'est à
Versailles 60 logements actuellement
construit de manière écologique le
chantier a débuté il y a maintenant six
mois le lycée Jean Vilar de plaisir
participent un bon cours des lycéens
soldes établissements en Île-de-France
ont été sélectionnés les élèves de
première littéraire ont deux mois pour
lire 11 livres ils devront se prononcer
le concours des lycéens sera remis le 15
novembre si vous cherchez un bureau une
étagère ou une voiture à moindre coût
rendez-vous sur le site de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin qui
mettent aux enchères certains de ses
biens la vente aura lieu à la fin de
cette semaine et puis une histoire
romantique celle du couple d'espères qui
vient de célébrer ses noces de platine
autrement dit 70 ans de mariage cette
vidéo et les vidéos de l'ensemble de nos
reportages et de nos émissions sont à
retrouver sur notre site Internet à
partir de maintenant à Thoiry le parc
animalier vient d'ouvrir son arche des
petites bêtes pas de Panda d'ours ou de
tigre mais des invertébrés et des
amphibiens principalement c'est une
opération inédite en France l'arche des
petites bêtes se veut un lieu d'élevage
de conservation ouvert au public bien
sûr reportage Anthony Rech
qui les regarde qui les aiment le
Scorpion la mygale ou l'escargot arrive
au zoo de Thoiry au sein de l'arche des
petites bêtes le public va partir à la
découverte de 70 espèces d'amphibiens et
d'invertébrés très souvent menacés
d'extinction mais pourtant si nombreuses
quand le grand public pense à la
sauvegarde de la biodiversité il pense
aux éléphants il pense au Rhino il pense
au panda OK et puis on oublie un petit
peu les petites bêtes mais elles sont
extrêmement importantes c'est un maillon
essentiel de la chaîne alimentaire et
pour vous donner une idée en fait les
mammifères par exemple il y a à peu près
6000 espèces et les invertébrés il y a
un million 300 000 espèces
au cours de ce voyage on passe du rêve à
la réalité de la découverte des méduses
Aurélie sous la mer aux espèces d'eau
douce pour finir à quelques mètres de là
par la zone nocturne et ses espèces de
la nuit les espèces qui font peur les
mygales les scorpions et leur présence à
un but faire comprendre l'importance des
bêtes invisibles j'aimerais que les gens
sortent en large réalisent justement à
quel point sont importantes toutes ces
petites bêtes et qu'en plus si ce soit
amusé parce que ça c'est important parce
que si ils vont s'intéresser à la
sauvegarde de ces espèces il faut que ce
soit amusé en même temps et qu'ils aient
vu comment eux peuvent aider à leur
échelle ne serait-ce que dans leur
jardin ou dans leur maison pour protéger
la nature lors de ce voyage les
visiteurs seront accompagnés par Noé le
prince de l'arche des petites bêtes
large des petites bêtes à découvrir à
Thoiry c'est la fin du 7 8 de ce mardi
sur TVfil les programmes se poursuivent
prochain direct de mon mercredi à 18h
avec une édition spéciale journée du
patrimoine en compagnie de Johanna
Soudry j'évoquerai les rendez-vous à ne
pas manquer dans le département je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée forcément